thoughts on the radical left and their
superficial view belief and value on the
environment how is this influenced by
their own raw emotions inviting
questionable immoral and dangerous
actions despite good intentions well I
don't really buy the whole good
intentions thing I mean I think that
it's really hard to have good intentions
like John the question I just answered
you know John said looking at myself
honestly I'm deeply envious and
resentful of others happiness well if
you listen to the Lindsey Shepherd
recording at Wilfred Laurier University
and you listen to the professor's and
that the administrators I think that
it's a it's it's absurd to start with
the presupposition that they have good
intentions I don't think they have good
intentions at all so but you know we
could give the devil let's do and say
that there are people on the left end of
the spectrum like like there are on all
parts of the spectrum who are trying to
do good things but having good
intentions and figuring out how to do
well in the world our good intentions
are only the beginning and people are
always influenced by raw emotions and
fuzzy thinking and it's hard to think
critically and it's hard to plan
strategically and it's hard to to
intervene in the world in a way that
doesn't cause trouble which is partly
why I recommend to people that they
start local you know you can't even
trust your own good intentions to some
degree because you have to test out what
you do when you have good intentions and
see if it actually produces the result
that's intended but I wouldn't make the
case to begin with that especially on
the radical end of the left I think it's
unbelievably motivated by resentment